one of the things that you see so
clearly right now is the media
continuing to just cover in every
possible way for the biden
administration it truly is
an incredible thing so the washington
post has a piece
today it is titled biden's low-key
approach to storm wins praise but courts
risks
now you will have noticed that ted cruz
was ripped up and down up and down for
not going and visiting
texas and handing out water bottles or
something instead going to cancun i said
that's real bad optics right it is bad
optics
joe biden has been completely absent
like really absent he signed the
emergency declaration i believe over the
last 48 hours
okay and the take from the politics
section at the washington post
is that biden is doing amazing his
low-key approach to storm
wins praise but courts risks democratic
state representative
james talarico says the most he's heard
of federal help in his area during the
devastating winter storm is a female
water truck that apparently got stuck in
ice
kp george the top elected official in
fort bend county texas said federal
officials have told him help is on the
way
just not fast enough we can't wait
another 72 hours to get food and
blankets and things like that he said
and u.s representative colin allred
democrat of texas
said what would help most beyond an
infusion of federal dollars is a visit
from president biden
this has been something like the dark
ages here in texas already said i mean
people are burning their furniture and
their fences for warmth and heat they're
finding older folks literally frozen to
death in their beds
when the president has toured seen the
damage spoken to the people who are
affected
i think that makes it a little bit hard
to say well i'm sorry you're going to be
on your own
as the biden administration faces its
first natural disaster says the
washington post
the president himself is taking a
notably low-key approach
he has not visited the stricken region
or delivered prime time remarks he did
not mention the disaster at a recent
town hall
and he is studiously avoiding the
controversy over whether wind energy or
fossil fuels are to blame for the
widespread power failures
it's a marked contrast to former
president donald trump
i'm sorry you have ever so the opening
paragraphs are
every democrat's like you know biden
should visit here and probably he should
you know
meet with some people and sign the
emergency declaration make sure the
federal aid gets here and the washington
post is like
yeah so um he's asleep in his basement
and he's been catching all the latest
episodes matlock
but at least he's not trump what the
hell does it matter what like trump
hasn't been president for a month guys
like what are you talking about
they say he famously tossed paper towels
to hurricane victims excoriated
californians for gross mismanagement to
forest
and called puerto rican leaders corrupt
and incompetent for their handling of
aid money
okay well first of all i remember when
you yelled at him for not visiting the
hurricane victims then he went and gave
paper towels to people
and then when he said that they
mismanaged their forests in california
that's because they did
as far as the puerto rican leaders and
their corrupting corruption and
incompetence they found millions of
water bottles lying on the tarmacs
in puerto rico in the aftermath of the
hurricane so i mean there's something to
be said for at least part of that
response
but that's really not what the piece is
about why is trump relevant here
what like if it were trump we all know
what the headline would be right
trump refuses to go to hard hit texas in
the middle
of horrifying calamity i love this from
the washington post
while biden has won praise for his
quieter more business-like approach
he is also running the risk that he and
the federal government can appear almost
absent
state and local officials say a big test
will come in the months and years ahead
as texans replace burst pipes and
flooded homes
clear out dead crops and livestock and
investigate the collapse of an
electrical grid that left
millions shivering in the dark okay so i
have a question
they've not said twice in this article
that he's
taking a low-key approach and uh he is
receiving praise for it
so i'm just wondering where's the praise
they have they've yet to cite we're not
like
11 paragraphs in there's no praise cited
anywhere
in here about what exactly he's been
doing but according to the washington
post
it is praiseworthy you have to get down
to paragraph you know 20 until you get
to this
the president this is uh daniel kanowski
a former fema deputy
administrator said the president has
authorized fema to provide physical
resources
and financial resources just as
important officials said is what biden
has not done
several credited him with not
politicizing the disaster he has not
weighed in
on some texas officials widely disputed
claim that the failure of wind turbines
was largely responsible for power
failures well that would be the smart
thing to do right i mean because if he
weighs in on that he's going to be wrong
the president has also respond refrain
from scolding state leaders for
decisions relating to their power grid
that might have contributed to the
electrical
collapse well right because if he gets
enmeshed in that particular thing that
is a battle he is going to lose
nonetheless biden has been silent about
the storm
since february 14th you know what the
headlines would be of trump or silence
about the storm since february 14th
right
he has tweeted that he and first lady
joe biden were keeping texas oklahoma
and other impacted states in our prayers
officials say it is a marked difference
from trump okay so here is the deal
no matter what joe biden does the media
will say it is the greatest thing he
wants to keep schools closed it's the
greatest thing he's going to
be really wishy-washy about the vaccines
greatest thing he's going to roll out
the vaccines greatest thing he's not
going to mention what's going on in
texas amazing he is going to mention
what's happening in texas unbelievably
good
all great okay because bottom line is
this
for the media that has an agenda the
only democrat who ever gets criticized
is one
they have lost use for andrew cuomo can
now be duly tossed out of the boat
because andrew cuomo is no longer useful
if you look at biden biden is still
useful
maybe there will come a point where he's
no longer useful but for the media
trying to generate a narrative the only
good democrat is a democrat who is
useful and when a democrat becomes not
useful that's when you can report on him
you're allowed to report on hunter biden
after the election you're allowed to
report on erdogano
after the election you're allowed to do
all sorts of these wonderful things as
soon as the time for actually doing them
when it would have made a difference
what is over you know there's such a
thing as a lie by omission and when your
media ignore
major stories for a year in order to
prop up certain politicians and then as
soon as those politicians become a
liability
they immediately just stab them directly
between the shoulder blades at that
point you might start to distrust your
institutional media
amazing amazing stuff i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the ben shapiro show if
you did go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content